GREGOIRE PEIRON:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
Ulku, welcome on stage.
So we switching back to English.
Thank you very much.
ULKU ROWE: Hi, everyone again.
Who here has been in the
keynote this morning?
So I apologize that you're
going to be subjected
to me for a little bit longer.
So today we're going to
talk about machine learning.
So who here thinks that we may
be at the height of machine
learning?
Everyone talks about
machine learning.
There's not a lot of clarity.
Yeah?
So I think we are at the
top of the peak cycle.
The phrase sheet
machine learning,
everyone talks about
it, but very few
people actually know what
to do about it really?
Anyone remember this image?
Anyone who watched "2001
The Space Odyssey?"
Raise your hands.
I knew I was in the company
of some nerds and geeks.
I watched it.
Remember that scene
says, "I'm sorry Dave.
I'm afraid I can't do that."
How about "Blade Runner?"
Any fans of "Blade Runner?"
Did you watch the new one?
Don't tell me.
I have not watched it.
I don't know if Deckard
is a replicant or not yet.
I'm holding on.
So anyway, this is
what some people
think machine learning is.
They think that machine
learning is on fast track
to singularity, and the
machines are going to take over.
And it may even be
the end of humanity.
This is what some others think
that machine learning is.
It's a bunch of data.
You put it all together.
You stir up a little bit.
You hope that something
good comes out of it.
But they think it's
a bunch of charades.
There's no value to it.
Well, this is what we
think about machine
learning at Google.
It is embedded into every
one of our products.
And it is very real.
And it's very much in use.
And so what is machine learning?
Now the ideal of artificial
intelligence is not new.
It's been around since the
early days of computing.
And it's captivated computer
scientists the early 1980s.
This idea of you don't
have to tell the computer
that everything it
needs to know up front
by being able to build
these machines that
know how to learn.
They know how to make
observations and do inferences
based on these observations
has been a field of computer
science for a long time.
Now on the field of deep
learning and particular,
is a under field of
machine learning.
And it's got a lot of general
use in computer science.
So it's a field that we at
Google look at very closely.
And this is how it works.
Think about how you learned
your very first language.
You know you didn't sit
there with a grammar
book and a dictionary.
You sat there with your
parents and your surroundings.
And you call the computer a
computer, you got a thumbs up.
If you called it a book,
they said no, no, no.
It's a computer.
So this idea of examples and
repeated practice and learning
is the same idea in
machine learning as well.
So in machine learning,
we expose a system
to many, many, many examples.
And those examples are
what teachers the machine.
Who here has played
Atari Breakout?
Any early Atari
Breakout players?
OK, there's a few.
So here is one where we
taught a neural network
to play Atari Breakout.
After 10 minutes of training,
it's pretty much random luck.
You The paddle's moving.
It's try to hit it,
but it's a hit or miss.
Now this is what happened
after two hours of play.
Now it's gotten pretty good.
It's not missing anything.
It's almost an expert.
Now watch this.
This is what happens
after four hours.
Just so you know,
the expert players
will know the way to win
in this game is you drill
a little tunnel through
the side and you
try to trap the ball there.
And that's how you
get the extra points.
So not only is the
computer learning,
but it is now building strategy.
And it's doing this
phenomenally fast.
After four hours, a human
being couldn't get this fast,
but obviously the
machine is there.
So why now?
Why are we talking about
machine learning today?
Why is it becoming such a hype?
Well, a successful
machine learning
has three things that it needs.
It is a good model
and powerful tools.
It needs lots of data
and good quality data.
And it needs lots of
computational power.
Now the models we've had,
we've had them for a while.
So the last two is now
what we're able to do.
Because now things like cloud is
able to give us massive amounts
of storage and on cost
effective computational power.
So we were able to do
pretty interesting things.
So let's look at how
we at Google have
been using machine learning.
So let's look at some examples.
So this is from our
source code repository.
These are the machine learning
models that we have today.
Now, if you look at 2012,
it's very little, very few.
Now you look at today, that's
an exponential curve that you're
looking at.
The growth is massive in
the way we internally are
making use of machine learning.
Who here has used Smart Reply?
Any users of Smart Reply?
So if you haven't, check
it out, because it's going
to save you a lot of time.
The first time we
did it, we did it
as an April Fools Day's joke.
We thought it was
never going to happen,
at least not in the short term.
But then we actually made
it a product in 2015.
And today, 10% of all email
replies come from this.
This just basically says
here are some sample
replies that you can send.
And all you have
to do is hit send.
The machine guesses
from the contacts.
Google Photos-- so recently,
my family was on a vacation.
We went to the beach.
And my mom asked
for some photos.
And we had hundreds--
I think we had 400,
500 pictures in there.
And I was looking for the
one to send to my mom.
So I looked-- I said
Southampton, beach, waves, Evan
and Ryan, the names of my boys.
And I was able to get
the photo instantly
without having to go
through all those photos.
Machine learning was
able to help me do that.
And we have a very happy
grandmother at the end.
And our data centers--
so we pay a lot of
attention to the power usage
of our data centers.
It's very important to us.
And it's not just because of the
cost, it's also because of what
the environment.
Now in our data centers,
we've built a lot of ways
to build super
efficient hardware.
We also looked at efficient
ways to pool our data centers
in some crazy ways.
And we invested heavily
in green energy.
Because we want to be 100%
powered by renewable energy
by the end of this year.
The real interesting thing is
we sent our DeepMind engineers
to look at our data centers.
We've been collecting a lot
of data from our data centers.
Now the complication with
them is obviously the way
the equipment works and the
environmental factors work.
And you know how everything
is, it's not a linear system.
So it's very hard to maximize it
looking at the traditional ways
of heuristic modeling.
So by doing that, looking
at things like sensors
from server racks, chillers,
and cooling towers,
and temperatures, and
pump speeds and weather,
all sorts of factors--
I think we looked at
maybe 120 of them--
we were able to bring down our
costs, cooling costs by 40%.
We did that and then
we didn't believe it.
We said wait a minute.
That sounds a little
too good to be true.
So when we did it, it
just jumped down by 40%.
So we said could
this be really true?
And we flipped it off and
it went right back up.
So then we knew it was for real.
It actually worked.
AlphaGo-- I think many
people in this room
are familiar with
AlphaGo, so I'm not
going to go too much into it.
But I do want to make one point.
I think if you remember
when IBM's Deep Blue beat
Kasparov, that was a big deal.
That was a game of chess that
was very hard to model prior.
But if you look at the
complexity of a game like chess
and AlphaGo and
make a comparison,
the number of possible
moves in a chess game
is equal to the number
of atoms in a human body.
The number of possible
moves in AlphaGo
is equal to the number
of atoms in the universe.
So it's a problem
that you can't just
solve by brute
computational power.
It's just not possible.
Well, maybe we get
quantum computers,
and I know it will be possible,
but today it's not possible.
So to do this, AlphaGo
had to build intuition.
Remember we looked at
the Atari Breakout game,
and that was about
building strategy.
In AlphaGo it was about
building intuition.
And I think that's
the thing I think
that's very impressive about
what our researchers were
able to do with AlphaGo.
So my mother, the same
mother that I sent
spent the pictures
to, she's a diabetic.
And she has been diabetic
for a very long time.
And there is about
400 million people
today in the world that
are at risk of going blind.
They're at risk of going blind
because of the very, very
simple illness.
And you really need two
things to treat this.
You need the retinal
scan of the eye.
And you need a very, very
highly trained specialist
to be able to look
at that retinal scan
to make the diagnosis.
And then the
treatments super easy.
Now of course the problem
is in many, many parts
of the world like
Africa or in India,
even part of United
States and I think Europe,
we do not have those
highly trained specialists.
So our researchers and
the Google Brain team
worked with physicians.
And what they were
able to do is apply
machine learning to this
particular eye disease where
the machine today can
diagnose this image,
at least as good as
highly trained physicians.
And I'm very thankful
that for personal matters,
but also for humanity.
So take a look at this.
So this is not me running,
although I do sometimes
run like that.
But this is a humanoid.
This is a humanoid
figure that was
trained by our DeepMind people.
And what they've done is they
didn't tell the humanoids
to virtual characters how to
walk or how to make progress.
They didn't teach them anything.
All they did was they gave them
virtual sensors that meant that
they would know if they
were upward or not--
where are they standing up--
or were they making
forward progress.
So the only thing
they were told to do
was to keep going forward.
So everything here, the jumping,
the limboing, the leaping,
it was everything that the
computer devised itself
as a way to get from A to B.
And the rest of it, the machine
did itself.
So if this was 2014, and
I was standing up here
and I asked all of you to
take your cell phones out,
and if everybody in the
world did the same thing
and we talked to our assistants
for about three minutes,
we would have completely
crashed Google.
It would go completely depleted
all the processing power.
Now we were doing some
really cool things,
but we were using a lot,
a lot of processing power.
So we decided to build our
own machine learning hardware.
So we built these things
called TensorFlow processing
units, TPUs.
Now there's two very interesting
properties of neural nets
and learning algorithms.
Property number one
is they don't need
as much precision in the math.
We don't need to
keep the n-th digit
in our mathematical
calculations.
The other thing is we only
need a handful of operations
that we really need
to do really fast.
And we don't need
the genericness,
the generality of the
general purpose computers.
So by using those
two properties,
we built these chips
which now allow
us to accelerate neural
network computations
by an order of magnitude.
And these are available today to
use in Google Cloud Platforms.
So it's not just Google doing
pretty amazing things today.
Our clients that
are using Google
are also doing some
really interesting things.
So let's take a look
at a few of them.
Any parents here?
Any parents?
Anyone with babies?
Or remember were
babies were like?
QP is a Japanese food producer,
and they make baby food.
And remember when our
babies were young,
we were very nervous about
what they were eating?
So when QP is making baby
food, every now and then
you get this discolored
pieces of potatoes.
And they're perfectly
fine to consume,
but if you are a nervous
parent with your first baby
in your arms, you don't want
that in your baby's food.
So what QP was allowed to do
is they used Google's machine
learning algorithms to train.
And they used about
18,000 photos as input
to this process to
automatically identify and get
rid of the discolored pieces
of potatoes in the baby food
to have more happier and
more content parents.
Ocado-- anyone
familiar with Ocado?
They are UK online
grocer and they have
about 500,000 active customers.
They're the world's largest
online only grocery store.
Because they only operate
in the online space,
there is only two ways that they
interact with their clients.
It's their ordering system,
where you go and make
your grocery shopping, and
it's their call center.
Those are the only ways.
They don't have a human
to human interaction.
So it's super important
for them to be
able to make the most of this
human computer interaction.
So their clients can call them,
tweet them, or email them.
So Ocado uses the Google
Cloud Platform and our machine
learning products to basically
prioritize and segment all
these incoming requests so that
the urgent request, something
that has to do with the quality
of your immediate delivery,
gets answered first, rather than
someone just sending an email
to thank them for their service,
which they get an email back
to, but it's not as immediate.
So using machine learning to
understand context and what's
happening in these
emails and tweets
and calls to be able to
serve their customers better.
Marine sanctuaries--
all over the world
marine sanctuaries are at risk
today due to illegal fishing.
Global Fishing Watch
aims to combat this.
Now one of the
problems though, they
get about $400 billion
location messages.
They get all GPS messages that
tells them where the fishing
vessels are, which is great.
You can know where all
the fishing vessels are.
The problem is
looking at this, you
can't tell if this is
just a vehicle passing by
or somebody doing
illegal fishing.
It's hard to do.
So it turns out that
you can tell them apart
by their moving patterns.
You can see here the trawlers
has a very different way
of moving than long lines.
So by looking at not
just the GPS signals,
but how they move
as they traverse,
they can actually
tell them apart.
So what they were able to do
by looking at these patterns,
they helped the
government of Chapati.
The government of Chapati
is this tiny little island.
They helped them to get
fines from illegal fishers
to the tune of $2.2 million.
To us, maybe that's
not a big money.
But that's about 1%
of their entire GDP.
So this was pretty impressive
what they were able to do.
The Cardus Labs-- one of
the things that they do
is satellite image processing.
Now this year what
they were able to do
was looking at
satellite images, they
predicted us corn production.
And they did that with
1.9% accuracy compared
to the USDA's final report.
What's really impressive is
they did this five months
before the actual
report came out.
Five months, that's
the advantage
that they were able to have.
They didn't have to wait
for the public report.
They looked at the
satellite images.
And they did it for themselves
and pretty accurately.
So machine learning
is very real and it
is making a very real impact
across all the industries.
Anyone here from manufacturing?
Manufacturing?
Are you guys using
machine learning?
So this is what your
competitors are doing.
They're doing
predictive maintenance.
They're doing the
man forecasting.
Anyone from retail?
Any retailers here?
There you go.
Are you using machine learning?
Let's see what they're doing.
Inventory planning?
Recommendation engines?
Anyone using machine learning
here in their businesses?
You're using.
What industry are you from?
Telecommunications, that's
not even on the list.
Well done.
Anyone else representing
other industries?
Media, of course media.
You guys are way ahead
of everyone anyway.
Anyone else?
Anyone else doing
representative?
Financials, thank you.
Any one of these on this list?
Risk management, I used
to do risk management.
Perfect.
So it's across everything.
It's across everything,
across every industry
that we're seeing it.
And this is a list taking
from our clients that are
doing this on our platforms.
So how can you get
started with this?
How can you get
Now everything that we have and
everything that our client does
is underneath it all is
powered by TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is our machine
learning algorithm.
It was originally developed
by our Google Brain team.
And in 2015 we open sourced it.
We open sourced it under
the Apache license.
And there's a
couple ways that you
can use TensorFlow yourself.
One, you can use the
fully trained models.
I think you've seen some
examples of these keynote
this morning, like our Video
Intelligence API and Vision
API.
And there is absolutely
no learning required.
You can use these
out of the box.
The other way that
you can use it
is either by using TensorFlow
machine learning libraries.
And you can use these--
because they're open source,
you can use them on prem.
You can use it on your laptop.
You can use it anywhere.
Or you can use our Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
which is our fully
managed platform, where
you can attach interesting
things like TPUs,
like GPUs, hardware
accelerators.
And because it's
fully managed, you
don't really have to worry
about installations and cores.
It scales on its own
to be able to do this.
So machine learning
is not a hype.
It's not a hype.
It looks like there's a lot
of hype, but it is very real.
And it is very real
for us at Google.
And I think it is very
real for our customers that
are doing some amazing
things on our platforms.
So we would love to
hear more from you
and hear more from
your examples.
And we would love to
take you on this journey
to machine learning as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GREGOIRE PEIRON: Thank
you very much, Ulku.
We're going to continue in
English now, another session.
Afterward it's French, OK?
So I have the pleasure to
welcome on stage David Roldan.
David is leading
our relationship
with the startup system.
And he's going to
talk to us about how
to innovate a startup.
So David, welcome on stage.
DAVID ROLDAN: Thank
you, Gregoire.
Hi, everyone.
Great to be here today.
So as Gregoire mentioned,
I lead all our startup
and investor engagement across
all of Europe for the cloud
organization.
So what does that mean?
It means that I also
run our startup program.
So we use that as a mechanism
to help companies to accelerate
and scale and grow.
And we're always looking
for different trends.
What works?
What doesn't?
What do the most
successful people that
are building what's next do?
What are the commonalities?
So today we'll talk about
some of those themes,
because the reality is
a lot of those themes
and a lot of the
underlying principles
can be used across virtually any
industry, any size a company,
larger or small.
So we'll talk about that.
So first, I want to start
with just a concept.
So we'll talk for
instance, Lee methodology,
widely known, widely used.
But many startups
are often taught
to be able to follow some
sort of the methodology
for the purpose of
making sure they have
a good strong feedback loop
for the purpose of trying
to make sure that
they understand what
their customers are saying and
ultimately, how do you iterate
and be able to get
features out there quicker?
A lot of it is simply
based upon the fact
that you have a limited amount
of resources, time, money,
people.
So that means that you've got
to be smart in how you operate.
The reality is most
of us fall into this.
And it doesn't matter
what size company you are.
The hard part is being
able to come up for air
and be able to
understand what is it
that our customers are saying?
And then how do
we prioritize what
they're say that's going
to yield us the greatest
value on the other side?
So a lot of that is
trying to figure out
how do we steer away from this?
How do we make sure that
we're operating as efficiently
as possible?
Because what we don't want
is for this to happen.
And I always loved this
picture, because the symbolism,
it just means so much.
From a startup
perspective it's hey,
are we effectively
managing burn rate?
From a large organization,
maybe it's multimillion budget.
But doesn't make it any better
if it's been put to waste.
And nothing meaningful
was achieved.
So this starts to have a shift
in how people are thinking
and the considerations that
they make, from hey, let's
try and achieve the holy grail
of continuous integration,
continuous delivery.
Because we want to be able to
iterate as quickly as possible,
get those features out
there to delight customers.
So that in itself is
easier said than done.
Many of us feel like this.
Certainly mind of
an entrepreneur.
Many can say the
barrier of entry
to start something new
has never been easier,
certainly with cloud.
But then the reality is kind of
going from that first million
dollar revenue to $10
million to $100 million,
et cetera has never been harder.
And many of you that
work and operate
in organizations
that have been around
for a very long time, that
can be a challenging thing.
There's a lot more data inputs,
a lot more considerations
that need to be taken
into account for.
So a lot of that can be kind
of synonymous with noise.
But the reality is, all the talk
about machine learning and AI,
it's wonderful and
Ulku is correct.
It's not a fad.
It's something that's built
to last and will be around.
But none of it means
anything without data.
Data trumps all.
And if you think
about most of the work
people do when it comes
to machine learning,
probably about 90% of that
work is about pre-processing,
data cleansing.
And only probably
about 10% and actually
trying to get those insights.
So you start to see a trend
of people that ultimately
are trying to figure
out how do we solve
for a lot of these challenges?
And they will apply
things like machine
learning to be able to
make sense of it all.
Because the reality is
there's a talent war
that exists out there in
trying to find people that
can help you be more agile.
And that's where
you start seeing
a lot more of the kind
of human resources
related startups being born.
Because it's hard
to find talent.
Where did these people exist?
If you consider that there's--
when I last looked--
there's about 21 million
professional coders
in the world.
How many of those are
deep learning engineers?
There's a lot less of those.
And then you start to have a
lot of this philosophical type
of conversations of who do we
want to be as an organization?
What type of culture do we want
to kind of have and instill?
Most companies have been
very centralized in how
they group and operate.
But now trying to figure
out how do we inject AI
into some of our products?
Because we think
it will massively
improve how people operate
and delight customers.
Now you start thinking
about well let's hire
people wherever they are.
So all of a sudden
it becomes well,
are we have fragmented
organization
or it's just simply we're
become a bit more decentralized.
So new conversations being had.
And startups across the
globe are faced with this,
especially because
they're always
faced with limited resources.
So they are trying
to find the best.
And then it's also how
do you retain the talent?
And for many of us, that can
be just as hard as finding
someone, if not harder.
As they say, good
people are hard to find.
So then you start
seeing new type
of companies being
born like PyCon
who's a Danish startup company.
Ultimately they
try and synthesize
all the kind of
data input of what
are our employees telling us?
And then trying to
make use of that data
so employees can figure out how
do we take the proper action?
And what's going to yield
us the greatest result?
Then beyond that, there's
also revenue and users.
Many of us, that's
why we're here.
Trying to figure out how
do we acquire more people?
How do we continue to grow?
And it's no different
for any type of customer.
But internally, we often talk
about the next billion users.
What does that mean?
How do you find them?
How do you attract them?
And really, that kind of is
synonymous with the last point,
which is data.
Data is the de facto king.
It's the currency
that matters most.
Because it's how you're
going to get the greatest
amount of insights, and that's
where you see a lot of people
gravitating more towards
trying to understand their data
pipelines and the
analytics pieces
to be able to kind of
make sense of it all.
In the past, I suppose
you could say, certainly
when I guess the internet first
kind of came of age that it was
much easier to
try and understand
what is it that we need to
know about our customers.
Now I think you can argue that
it's never been more complex.
Because now we want
to know everything.
Because it is about data.
And making one change
here or a slight variable
could have a much larger
impact than we would otherwise
have known.
So now it's much more about
how do we make sense of it?
But this is where
you start to see
a lot of that
shift going into we
want to get into
predictive analytics
or predictive behavior.
That's when we start getting
into the machine learning.
And with that though,
I do caution people.
Because it's very easy
to say, hey, we're
going to go down
that rabbit hole.
And we're going to build a
machine learning capable team.
We're going to hire a bunch
of data science engineers.
But one of the kind of
biggest fallacies, or I
guess one of the biggest
mistakes I often see people do
is they didn't
understand the use case.
Because more often
than not, the use case
for people that want
to do machine learning,
there's something that they
could use that's off the shelf,
pre-trained API.
So there's been a lot
of talk about it today
between the key
note and whatnot.
But certainly natural language,
OCR, Vision API, speech text,
et cetera, a lot of those are
being leveraged and utilized.
Now that said, every now and
then we hit a fork in the road
where it actually makes sense
to go and build your own models.
But I do urge you to make sure
that you understand that use
case.
Because if there are things
that you can use, great.
That way you don't have to
incur a lot of technical debt.
But if you do have
to go out and embark
on building your own,
then the top two questions
we always get--
certainly I always get from
startups and investors is--
how do we get
access to data sets?
And how do we hire these people?
What do we find them?
So there's many
ways to go about it.
Kaggle is a wonderful way
to be able to try and solve
for those things.
In the interest of
transparency, Google
did acquire Kaggle
in March this year.
But I think what
the magic of Kaggle
is that it's effectively a
data science marketplace.
And people will post
competitions there.
And I always tell people
if you're looking to hire,
then post the competition.
The people that can solve
the problem, the challenge,
go hire them.
There will be other
people that are just
kind of talking about it.
They're probably full of
it and don't hire them.
And then routinely
Kaggle and people
that contribute to
that marketplace
are posting new datasets
virtually every day.
And I think now with
Google acquiring them,
we're going to be
pushing even more there.
So Dr. [INAUDIBLE],,
who heads up kind
of machine learning
within Google Cloud,
quite often she's always talking
about the democratization
of AI.
She's a firm believer in that.
And I think that's a
very important thing.
And I think that's why
you'll start to continue
to see us go down that path.
And I think that's a good
natural segue to what is yet
another trend that you see
a lot of startups using,
but how does that relate
to the greater population?
A lot of that is open
source technologies.
Now more than ever, people are
building from the ground up
using open source.
And there's a variety
of reasons for that.
Some of it just
from a pure ability
to maintain costs
more effectively.
But then an even bigger
emphasis is largely
on the speed to innovation,
the power the community.
So when I think
about Kubernetes,
I think the latest release
1.8 came out a few weeks ago.
But when I think
about the 1.7 release,
I think it was only a
few months prior to that.
So there's something to
be said about the power
of the community and
that acceleration.
And the top two open
source projects on GitHub
are Kubernetes and TensorFlow,
both Google projects.
I don't know that we
necessarily intended
or thought that it would
end up that way, but it has.
And there's not a day
that goes by where I'm not
talking to a startup
or investor that
is trying to better understand
how they can leverage those
to keep smaller teams, but
be able to scale infinitely.
And then a third open source
project out there, Apache Beam.
So I won't go through a
massive amount of history.
But what I will
say is if you think
of the first MapReduce
papers that Google
wrote, released into the wild.
Someone took an interpretation
of that and created Hadoop.
And then we released more
papers and then Spark was born.
So Hadoop for batch
processing, Spark for stream.
So Apache Beam effectively
is combining that.
And the hosted Google
Cloud version is data flow.
And I always say
the magic of it is
you can do both batch
and stream in real time.
Amazing.
But one of the trends that we
do see amongst a lot of startups
is they are using Dataflow to
continuously keep models fed.
And that's a very
powerful thing.
So those of you that
aren't familiar,
it might be a consideration.
So now from here
on out, I wanted
to focus on a few
use cases of startups
that they were born purely out
of use in machine learning.
So [INAUDIBLE] is a startup.
And they are using
OCR, so Vision API.
And effectively as
you can see, they'll
be able to take pictures
and be able to have
that be categorized with
some of the partners
that they work with.
So large brand
retailers like Target.
They even work with
Daimler Chrysler
to be able to take pictures of
their entire fleet of trucks
to be able to
understand which ones
are in good condition,
which ones that are in
need of repair.
So that's a great example of
being able to leverage a Vision
API, but then also
for some things
that they might take pictures
of like labels and brands,
then being able to use the
NLP API, natural language
processing to be
able to understand
blocks of text of what are
our customers saying about us?
And then how do we use
that to be able to iterate?
Another one is a more
traditional industry.
So farming-- so
in this case this
is a Japanese cucumber farm.
And you can think of
it in terms of it's
been a family business for ages.
And son goes off to university
and prodigal son returns.
And his parents have always
taught him there's nothing
more important than quality.
But it was a laborious
manual process.
And everything had
to be done by hand
to sort out which ones are good
cucumbers, which ones are not.
And what he did is he got
a raspberry pie, hooked up
a camera to it, download
a TensorFlow model locally
to the device.
And 7,000 pictures later, voila.
So pretty cool.
And then the last one I
wanted to share with you
is a company called Ravelin.
So they are effectively helping
to solve for credit card fraud
detection.
So it's very cool
in how they're used
in machine learning to do that.
So I'm going to play
a video for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In addition to using machine
learning to catch fraudsters,
we use something called
network graph analysis.
And on screen you'll see
a really simple network.
It consists of a single person
and a single credit card.
Now don't be fooled by
that cute smiling face.
That's actually a fraudster
and it's a stolen credit card.
And if there was
another fraudster
who used the same card, you'd
see them all linked together
as well.
So this is just a
more complex version
of what you saw
previously, just with have
many more cards and many more
fraudsters all linked together.
And I think it looks
pretty beautiful.
And what you're looking at here
is an organized crime ring.
In this particular case,
we worked with the police
and we gathered enough evidence.
And we were able to put a
stop to the entire network.
And we're particularly
proud of this
because it's a great
feeling knowing
that the technology
we built help
put a stop to
professional criminals.
And this was the height
of our achievement
until we came
across this network.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Internally we call
this the Death Star.
[LAUGHTER]
There are tens of
thousands of nodes.
And the most awesome thing
about networks of this size
is that when our machine
learning model catches
a single fraudster,
because they're all
connected in a network, we
can put a stop to thousands
of accounts instantly.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So wonderful work Lenny and
the team at Ravelin are doing.
But this hopefully
should give you
a semblance of a very
real world problem, fraud,
that exists out there.
And obviously, it's wonderful
to see the kind of social impact
that they have, but using
world class technology
to be able to achieve that.
So I always provide
a bit of guidance,
because there is this
kind of pent up demand
and talk about AI
and machine learning.
And the reality is, we need to
start thinking about in terms
of it's own category.
The truth is that
it's going to be
a fabric of every company
that exists going forward.
Now some companies, it might
be very core to what they do.
Others it just might
be an ancillary piece
that they add in
because it might
be able to somehow move
the needle in how they're
able to delight customers.
But I do urge everyone to
consider that they do it
for the right
reasons, whether it's
because you want to change
humanity, want to be a world
beating company and
create a new category,
or become a category leader.
And certainly from a startup
perspective, I always say,
don't do because you want to
raise some crazy valuation
or for an acqui-hire,
because ultimately, you'll
be setting yourself
up for failure.
But do it for the right
reasons, because it's very easy
to get caught up in this buzz
word bingo and all the nonsense
that comes with it.
As I said, it will
exist, and it will
be a part of businesses
going forward.
But it's very important
to take into consideration
about everything
today is about speed.
And it's about velocity.
And I love that word
velocity, because velocity
encompasses two main
things, speed and direction.
So it's ultimately
trying to make sure
that you understand
where you're going,
and you're doing it
at the right speed.
But the ability to
do that is going
to be about the underlying
technology that you use,
and always keeping the customer
at the forefront of what
you're going to do.
So I'll leave you with that
and I appreciate your time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GREGOIRE PEIRON: Thank
you very much, David.
Super useful, thanks.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
ANTONY PASSEMARD: Merci.
Merci.
[APPLAUSE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
GREGOIRE PEIRON:
BASTIEN LEGRAS:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
GREGOIRE PEIRON:
[APPLAUSE]